am freitag für den am rathausplatz in
der marktgemeinde dresden die feierliche
angelobung der melker pioniere unter der
anwesenheit von verteidigungsministerin
klaudia tanner stadt
rund 160 grundwehrdiener dass ein
rettungs termins april 2022 sprechen er
treu
für die jüngsten ist hinter der drummer
erwähnt in ihrer ansprache die hohe
bedeutung der pioniere
für die 146 angetretene rekruten des
pionierbataillons
mitteilt in den kommenden monaten ihren
dienst zum schutz
die pioniere stehen bei katastrophen und
unglücksfällen der bevölkerung immer
wieder mit vielfältigen hilfeleistungen
zur seite
[Applaus]
[Musik]